[SOUND] It's my great
pleasure to have
Rodrigo Castano from University
of Buenos Aires visiting us.
He's a PhD student there, and
working on making model checkers
more accessible to users.
And look forward to the talk,
welcome.
>> Right, thanks, thank you for
the introduction, Shivendu.
And again,
I'm gonna be talking about,
well, explaining inconclusive
outcomes from software
model checkers to users.
And this will mostly
cover my PhD work,
and it'll extend a little bit
into the future, with stuff that
I would look forward to do in
the next few months/years.
So let's start with motivation.
So why do I wanna care about
inconclusive model checker
results?
Well, because I might wanna
check any of the properties
that you have on your right.
And we have assertions in the
code, and we have assertions of
invariance, and
it's just regular C code.
We're not dealing with models,
we're actually dealing
with source code.
And I might just choose a model
checker that I like, I might
choose a set time limit that
I have, maybe it's 1 minute,
maybe it's 15 minutes,
half an hour, whatever time.
I run my software model checker,
and then I come back, and
I get unknown,
time limit exceeded, or
maybe memory limit exceeded, or
maybe it had an obstruction and
we find an error, or
any of those things.
Or maybe I'm using a bounded
model checker, and I get, well,
I didn't find a bug, but
I've reached the bound,
so it's still an unsound result.
So what do I get from this?
This is not a really
useful result,
because what do I do next?
Do I extend the time of it?
Do I trust the code?
Can I trust the code?
Can I just commit this code
that doesn't have any tests,
and just use it like this?
Should I change the technique?
It's not really useful, right?
So I feel like this is
a topic that actually
requires attention.
And I think it could
have an impact, and
we're gonna talk about how
it could have an impact.
So let's take a step back.
So we have basically
two ways of seeing verifications/bug-finding,
right?
So we have bug-finding
techniques,
such as bounding model checking,
fuzzing, [INAUDIBLE] execution,
and all that.
And basically, the workflow is,
you test your system until
basically, you've tested enough,
and you assume that your
system works, right?
You put it in production,
it runs, and
then, well, if it bugs,
it has bugs.
But then you have the opposite,
sort of.
And obviously,
usually the type of systems that
are tackled by each of these
techniques are different,
right, that's why you also
have different baselines.
So if you're working with
assisted or automatic
verification, but you're trying
to have full verification,
maybe your baseline is, well,
my program might have bugs,
unless I find full proof that
the program is safe, right?
So what you do is, you attempt
verification, and maybe you
timeout, or you get some
counterexample that's superior.
And then you simplify
the property and
then you simplify the program or
refine the abstraction.
Essentially, you work on
the instance of verification,
then you try again.
And if you can't manage to
get a conclusive result,
then you basically assume that
your program is not safe.
You don't have any guarantees,
you don't know how far your
model checker went, right?
So both of these
approaches have, sorry.
>> Are you talking about
user assisted verification?
How does this fit in there?
>> Yeah, so-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> If you're working with, for
instance, Dafny, right, and
you have to add invariants or
whatever, and you get
a timeout and stuff like that.
Well, you try and
simplify your properties, and
maybe just look under the hood,
why is it timing out?
And then you split
your properties, and
then maybe you add invariants
and so on and so forth.
But unless you have a full
proof, you won't say, okay,
well, I've tried for maybe two
hours, this must be good, right?
Usually you don't do that.
That's not the workflow
that most people follow.
>> You're saying
that the problem is,
you have a black box.
And [INAUDIBLE] you don't
have a good explanation for
why, and so you're hacking it.
You're like, maybe if I,
is that the [INAUDIBLE]
you're describing?
>> No, what I'm saying is that-
>> You're trying-
>> Yeah, so what I'm saying is
that usually if you're
an expert user,
you will have some insight as
to what you're supposed to do.
But unless you reach full proof,
you won't assume that
your program is safe.
You won't get halfway through
the proof and be like, I mean,
I'm pretty sure this works.
Usually when you're doing that,
you won't assume your
program works, right, sorry.
>> If you're using Dafny, then
the expectation, I think, is you
have a property and a program,
and you're trying to prove.
>> That's right.
>> Right, so if it's timing out,
the user assumption is, I
haven't gotten it approved yet.
>> That's right, yeah.
>> But I don't know, I might
have all the information.
All the information might be
present, it's just the theorem
prover's not good enough
to do it right now.
I have to do something.
>> That's right, so
what would you assume about the
system is sort of my question?
Would you assume that
the program is safe to use?
Would you release it into
production without a full proof?
Do you have any notion
of how far you've got?
Yes, sir.
>> So what about the case where
there's a property that I know
holds as a programmer, right?
I know that property holds, and
I can't prove that property.
Now if you could just assert
the property is true, I mean,
that way the proof
would go through,
assuming that it doesn't
timeout for some reason,
which that's a whole
different category of issue.
But the point is, I think
the human can get a little bit
of sense that he can help
the theorem prover by giving it
sort of extra information
that the program has, but
the verification system doesn't.
>> That's what he means by
simplify the property, so
we're adding an assumption that
you know would be simplified.
>> Yeah, okay, but at that
point then, why would you stop,
in some sense?
Cuz you can always give
it enough information?
>> Yeah, but the question is, at
some point, maybe you think that
a property holds, but
you're not absolutely sure.
I mean, if you know
that a property holds,
you definitely add it
to your assumption.
I mean, and then you have a
conclusive verification result.
But if you don't
reach that point,
if you keep iterating on this,
and you're like,
okay, I'm adding assumptions
that I'm not really sure hold
right now because I don't really
know what this lever does, or
this other thing.
Then maybe you wanna know, well,
are my assumptions too strong?
When does this assumption
actually affect me?
Is this relevant to my system or
not, right?
So problems, well, bug finding
and testing doesn't really
have that many guarantees,
cuz you're testing.
So if you didn't find a bug,
you don't know whether
there exists one or not.
>> So it has a guarantee
if you find one.
>> Well,
if you've found one, yeah,
but if you haven't found one,
you don't have many guarantees.
And the problem with the other
approach is that, well,
it's kind of all or nothing.
If you follow that idea,
that paradigm of, okay,
if I don't have a full proof,
then I'm now gonna give up,
then it's kind of all or
nothing, right?
If you didn't manage to
make the whole proof,
all of the effort that you
spent on it Is wasted.
And you have to start over with
whatever other technique you're
gonna use.
And then, to be honest,
there's not that many people
using these sort of techniques,
right, in industry.
Basically, testing is way
more widespread than formal
verification techniques,
in the sense of trying
to achieve a full proof.
So what if we take a different
perspective, right, and we use
these sort of verification
tools, but we use them in a way
as, okay, this could be
better than testing, right?
But I wanna know how
good it was, right?
And let's assume that Visual
Studio checked every assertion,
memory safety, and
I'm doing a little bit of
science fiction here, right?
But it checks all of
these properties,
system API is [INAUDIBLE],
then we have a dashboard
showing us how good the
verification attempt was, right?
So we have maybe on the left
the things that were probably
checked, that we got
a complete safe result, and
we have the proof that it holds.
And we have on the right
maybe the warnings,
and we could have different
kinds of warnings.
We could have warnings that
might be false positives, and
then they can be ranked
according to how likely that
it's a false positive, or Or
that it's a true positive, and
then in the middle,
we have a sort of an explanation
of what your model checker did,
right?
What sort of behaviors did it
cover, what part of the code did
it cover, do you have any
code coverage things?
And maybe,
suppose this is all integrated
into the code review process.
And instead of asking
your developer, okay,
whenever you're checking code,
I want you to test your code.
Maybe have a separate dashboard
that goes, okay, well,
this was tested in
the back end in Azure.
And all these parts of the code
were actually tested, and
the parts of the code that
were not are these edge cases.
Maybe that would kind of
change how we use verification
tools, right?
And okay, I said I was doing
a little bit of science fiction,
but honestly, what parts of
this are not present yet?
We can already check all
these assertions, and
if it is fully verified,
that's the column on the left,
we can show that, right.
And then we have, we can
definitely produce warnings.
We can produce warnings with
different levels of guarantees,
and we can also rank them.
We have angelic verification, we
have [INAUDIBLE] specifications.
And all that allows us to rank
different warnings, right, but
we don't have the stuff
in the middle.
We don't really explain what
happened in the cases when we
don't have a warning, but
we don't have a full proof, and
that's a lot of cases.
So maybe if we had that, and
just maybe that might be the one
element that keeps all of
the rest things together,
and makes it reasonable
to integrate
it into a mainstream idea
like Visual Studio, right?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> You can combine differently,
it could be a combination of
maybe your testing plus whatever
verification efforts you have.
But essentially, you would
have an idea of what parts of
the code were not
actually exercised,
what parts of the system
behaviors are not checked yet.
Okay, this was a little bit of
wandering around in my mind, but
let's talk about how my work at
my PhD fits into what already
exists, and how is that
a step forward or not.
And okay, let's start with two
papers that are actually from my
research group, the first one,
my model checker died,
how well did it do?
What it does basically,
it gives you a measure,
it gives you a-
>> Do they have to go together?
>> [LAUGH] Pretty much,
that's what you're asking, yeah?
So it gives you some
probabilistic measure,
why is that?
Because it tackles probabilistic
model checking of Markov chains,
right.
And what it asks for the user
is the usage profile, so
you need to give it some idea
of how the system is used.
So that it can tell you, well,
if that's the probabilistic
distribution of methods or
input or whatever.
Then this is how much of the
state space you have explored.
So that's asking a little
bit too much of a software
developer.
But also, this does not really
scale that well to software
model checking of
actual source code.
Besides, it's super sensitive
to those usage profiles that you
provide, so it's not ideal,
there's definitely room for
improvement.
Then alloy plus [INAUDIBLE],
alloy is a specification
language that is
specifically suitable for
structural properties, so
it's good to specify, maybe,
data structure invariants.
And the way it works is,
it bounce the constraints, and
then it translates them into
propositional logic, and
then it checks them
with a SAT solver.
And the idea behind this
paper is essentially, okay,
let's try to get some statistics
on which variables and
clauses are involved
in most conflicts.
And lift that up and
show it to the user, so
that the user can pay
attention to those, and
maybe organize them
in a different way.
So it's kind of heuristic,
and it's limited to alloy,
it doesn't necessarily
apply to other
types of techniques and
languages.
But anyway, this is part of the
stuff that we're building on,
and then the most related work
is basically conditional model
checking, which I work
on top of, basically.
And then explicit assumptions,
which you probably know,
cuz you had Maria here.
I think the original paper was
collaborative verification and
testing with explicit
assumptions, or
something like that.
And then bounded up
to interpretation,
which I'm not gonna
mention much, but
it's basically built on top
of explicit assumptions.
And let's talk about conditional
model checking a little bit.
So we have this example,
right, and
the true branch of the code
can be easily proved safe,
using some sort of predicate
abstraction, why is that?
Because we don't to need to sort
of unroll the loop too many
times, right?
If we drag the predicate,
i is greater than or equal to 1
million, then it's easy to prove
that the true branch is correct.
However, if we're using
predicate abstraction,
the nonlinear condition on
the false branch of the if might
be hard to prove, right, so your
model checker might give up.
So what they propose is, okay,
it would be good if that failed
attempt could sort of give some
of that knowledge forward,
to whatever is subsequent
verification attempt, right?
So what they propose is,
instead of having model checking
have three possible results,
true means that the probability
holds, false means that there's
another example and it
produces it, and then unknown.
Maybe we can only have false and
then true under certain
conditions, that's
the general idea, right?
So that subsequent verification
attempts can use that condition
to sort of constrain
their state space.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, that's right,
so that's the general approach.
Now they instantiate that for a
particular kind of analysis, and
that's abstract
reachability trees.
And what they produce,
their condition,
is an assumption automaton.
Right, and I'm gonna talk
a little bit about assumption
automaton and reachability trees
in the next few slides because
it's relevant for my work.
But let's just look at
this example for a second,
cuz I think it's really easy
to follow what's going on.
So we have an edge that
goes from the root node
to the node labeled true, right?
And that edge is labeled by the
condition none that basically
holds.
So that means if you enter
the den branch of the code,
then you're safe.
The true node means that all of
that portion of the state space
has been verified.
So every subsequent analysis
does not need to check that.
So this is useful because maybe
you're using explicit value
analysis afterwards.
And then that would
get stuck in the loop,
if you couldn't discard
that whole state space, so
that's an interesting idea,
right?
So that's basically
their use case and
how they show that
it could be useful.
And now let me explain a little
bit how abstract reachability
trees work and what they are.
>> So was the other branch not
interesting for us to look,
it's just the false branch?
Yeah, the other side,
the else branch,
what was happening there?
>> Yeah, so the else branch
is sort of unrolled in a way,
because the thing is, the model
checker had trouble getting rid
of the spurious counterexample,
right?
So it has a non-linear
condition, it has, sorry,
it has an assertion that says
that r is greater or equal to x,
and r is x squared, so
it's always gonna hold.
But since it's nonlinear,
it might have some trouble
getting rid of that
counterexample, right?
So what it does is,
when it cannot not refine
the obstruction, it gives up.
And it gives up telling you,
well, I explored everything, but
I have this part of the state
space that I haven't explored,
because I couldn't get
rid of it, basically.
>> So false means that
it is possibly false?
>> It means that that part of
the state space has not been
explored.
I'm gonna explain this in
a little bit more detail after
I explain reachability trees,
cuz otherwise it's
kinda hard to follow.
>> Just to go back a little bit,
so
does this actually
happen in practice?
What are the kinda situations
where you have that
kind of result?
Is there literature that says
it's a common thing, or that-
>> In the paper,
they have an evaluation
which SB kind of businesses.
I don't know if that happens a
lot in practice, but then again,
it's sort of a chicken and
egg problem.
We don't really use
verification a lot in practice,
then SB kind of.
>> Do you mean the verifier or
specifically-
>> Well, if you had this Yeah,
that verification can help
you with part of the code,
but that may be [CROSSTALK]
>> [INAUDIBLE] Almost
everywhere.
>> So that mean that
verification generally doesn't
work, cuz otherwise you would
wanna have this, right?
>> [LAUGH] It does but
[INAUDIBLE]
>> That's very important,
you get false alarms.
>> Yeah,
I guess it comes down to-
>> How many of these do
you have?
>> I think it's very
frequent because,
I mean, the parts of
are very complex and
you just lots of in
that part of the code.
>> So basically,
if I think of it abstractly,
I can have a whole set of
different analyses and
the abstract reachability
tree lets me
basically say what this analysis
was able to prove true.
>> And then it basically
wasn't able because
of whatever imprecision.
It could be imprecision
in the abstract domain.
It could be a timeout.
But whatever it is you could
summarize the state space of
what was explored and
proved true, and then the rest.
>> Yeah, that's right, so
that's their idea, basically.
>> And then you take this
thing and you can pass it on,
it's a representation.
This thing may be huge,
I mean, the [INAUDIBLE].
>> This thing is huge, yeah.
>> I mean,
we did this in Slam, right?
We had the model checker,
we had the BVDs, and yeah,
we could persist the BVDs, but
somehow we never really
did that for some reason.
I mean, we learned a lot through
the states space, but yeah.
>> Yeah,
I agree it is definitely huge.
But anyway, so
that's their use case and
that's how they show
that it could be useful.
Abstract Reachability Trees,
basically,
you probably
are familiar with it but
I'll just go over it quickly
just to make it self contained,
are trees that where its nodes
correspond to a state in
the of the code, and its edges
are labeled with statements.
And the way it works is it
keeps a wait list of nodes that
haven't been explored yet.
So these are the ones in orange
that have the big arrows that
say unexplored.
Then you pop a node
from the waitlist and
then you add its successors
to the waitlist, basically.
That's what it does
all the time until
it finds a target node, right?
So in this case the red node,
node seven, is an error node.
The thing is, it's unfeasible,
or no, and why is that?
Well, because the path that it
takes, is well it assigns five
to I, then it checks whether
I is greater than zero, and
it goes on the false
side of the condition.
And that cannot happen, because
five is greater than zero.
So that's the reason why it's
not feasible, and it goes on and
then it reaches
the air condition.
So what do we do?
We associate to that node in the
accessibility tree a predicate.
Why is that?
Well, because accessibility
tree nodes are associated with
an element of
an abstract domain.
That sort of makes
them versatile.
But if we had, for instance,
blast is based on abstract
reachability trees and their
domain is the predicates, right?
So we add that predicate.
And what happens next?
Well, that defines implicitly
a reachability region, right?
So we will be able to get
the whole subtree that
hangs from node four and
remove it because we know
that the predicate, know i
is not greater than 0, does not
hold under the node 2, right?
So we remove that.
What do we get?
We get this, right?
So we only get the unexplored
node three and the waitlist, and
then we pop it.
And then we add it's successors
and then we have another node,
and then we pop it, and so on.
So if we finished right now and
we timed out,
then our assumption would look
pretty much like this but
without the predicate and
the node 2 because assumption of
data only exposes the structure,
but not the domain elements.
So basically that's an overview
of, Conditional law checking and
absolute soliditaries.
Now let's go with
explicit assumptions.
So what they do,
It's proposed an extension to
the specification language such
that we have something that
behaves a lot like
assumed statements, sir?
>> [INAUDIBLE] Go back to that?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> So what is the property of
this Abstract Reachability Tree
that if there is an error
in the original program,
there is one in the-
>> In the full Abstract
Reachability Tree, but you're
building it on the fly, so yeah.
>> I see, so this just
says where you left off,
it doesn't say-
>> That's right.
>> The rest, okay.
>> Sir,
what do you mean the rest?
>> It's not a compliment
on what you verified.
>> Not really a compound.
Well, I mean it will represent,
so basically the property of
the Abstract Reachability Tree
is that every feasible system
execution will either lead to
a node in the wait list, or
it will lead to a true node,
basically.
That would the probability
of the assumption on
that you produce.
So it's an over-approximation
in that sense.
Then I have explicit
assumptions and
what's the use case that
Chris Tucker had in mind?
Basically, it's a good
way of annotating what
unsound assumptions were
made during verification.
So one good example is that
there's no integer overflow,
right?
We have unbounded integers.
So it's pretty clear if
you're using adaptive and
then you've got this assume
statement you might realize,
wait, in the language
that I'm trying,
maybe I do have
integer overflows.
I might need to pay
attention to this.
These annotations are really
useful for local assumptions.
They're maybe not that great for
the type of assumptions that
you make,
that you wanna capture in right?
Why is that?
Well, because for instance
when you have rolling, and
they actually check this in
their paper, in the explicit
assumptions paper,
it's kinda hard to express this.
It's actually impossible to
express it just with the assume
statements.
So what they do is they
have to transform the loop.
So you have to transform
the code in order to
add these assumptions.
But then again I feel
like there's room for
improvement, right?
So it's what we were talking
about before, where you add
an assumption that you might not
be sure whether it holds or not.
And it might be buried deep
inside your code in some
obscure function that
you sometimes call.
And you wonder, well, when
are these assumptions broken?
When do they hold?
Is it relevant that I
added this exemption?
Is it not relevant?
Anyway, so yeah?
>> So the statement here
means the loop has to
incur at least once,
that's what the assume knot?
>> Yeah, some what they do,
is they loop once,
and they assume the second
time you don't enter.
So it's bounded checking,
it's once, basically.
With one iteration, right?
But if you wanna do this for
more than one iteration,
then you have to unroll it in
the code and that's not ideal.
I think that makes it
way less understandable.
So there's definitely room for
improvement here, right?
Because you don't know how
relevant these assumption are.
And then the same thing happens
with conditional launching.
Let's go back to
what we said before.
You asked me, well,
what does it mean that you
have a false state here?
What it means-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sorry, yep.
>> No they are, yep.
So that's why other
studies that they did was,
basically, checking how
relevant these assumptions,
these unsound assumptions where
across different [INAUDIBLE].
Which is part of the sound in
it's manifesto [INAUDIBLE].
So back to conditional
model checking.
Well, is this
a perfect solution?
Well, the thing is, suppose
you expose this to your user?
Well, first of all, yeah,
it's gonna be huge,
which is what Tom mentioned.
But other than that, you see a
false statement and you might be
wondering, well, how relevant
is that false statement?
Well, it's not really
relevant because it's
not reachable there, right?
So you need to do
something about it in order
to interpret it.
So basically this is
where we start from.
So what is my approach?
Well, I have two
different approaches.
One of them is
Execution reports.
So what we do is we present
a report that captures safety
assurances in terms of
system executions and
the relationship to the safety
property of interest, right?
And then we have another
approach, which is coverage,
which is sort of The opposite.
Meanwhile while
execution reports aim for
detail coverage aims for
[INAUDIBLE].
And it is an intuitive
definition,
it's comparable to textbook
coverage which is interesting,
cuz you get a way to compare two
totally different techniques.
But they're kind
of complementary.
So let's start
execution reports.
So as I mentioned,
what you do is you
create a report based
on system executions.
And concretely, what we do
is we provide two sets of
system executions, one is
the exploration frontier, and
the other one
are the safe cones.
Essentially, if you've already
followed the whole part about
a conditional model checker
what we try to find is paths
that are feasible, that lead to
the safe the true states and
the false states.
And what does it mean for
an execution to be in
the expression frontier?
Let's look at
the example on the left.
We have a verification harness
that exercises the operation,
two operations of a stack.
We have push and pop.
And then it
non-deterministically
chooses the operation.
It calls a function and
then it checks whether
the variant holds, right?
And does that forever,
basically.
So what does it mean to have
the execution pushed first in
the exploration frontier?
Well, what it means is that
that's the precise point where
the analysis gave up, right?
So when it was reaching
the second push call,
it had to stop for whatever
reason, timeout or anything and
then it didn't exploit
that system execution, but
it didn't explore any of
its continuations, right?
Any possible extension for it.
And the same holds for
push pop, right?
So if you had to, you just
finished your model checking
attempt and you left it for
half an hour.
Will you be like, okay?
Ready to go to production,
maybe it wouldn't, right?
Because you're like, you
didn't check any of the border
conditions that I might
me interested in, right?
So this is not great, cuz you
still have to do something.
You have to test your system or
something.
But at least you know that your
model checking attempt was
definitely not good enough.
And what might happen to you,
if you're using Bonet model
checking technique is,
well, you get the idea that,
okay, it didn't present you any
warnings, but it didn't really
go that far, because whatever it
couldn't skip some loop or
something like that, anyway.
>> But don't we run into
the same problem here?
I mean, the model checker is
gonna grow a lot more, so
isn't your exploration frontier
and it's going to be huge?
>> Well,
that's a great question.
And actually it's not.
But I mean it depends on what
instances your looking at.
>> If it's a set of traces,
it seems like it
could be a very large set and
many of these traces are sort
of similar to others.
I mean, you're trying
to sort of summarize
an exploration which
inherently could be,
the program besides that and
this could be exponential.
>> That's true.
>> Right.
So it seems-
>> I can talk
about that a little bit. Yeah.
>> Okay.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, I had
the same question, I mean,
I guess with model checking the
underlying assumption is that
with even a small like if you're
concurrency or something like.
Even with a small number
of threads you're
going to find bugs.
You're not gonna find the bugs
when there's 16 threads,
because it's way too far.
But the whole point
of stopping is,
if you keep going your state
gets bigger and bigger, right?
And so it's seem that this
frontier you're talking about
will just get exponentially
larger, like Tom was saying,
what would a person do
with that at that point?
>> That's kinda true, let me
tell you about that first, and
then I'll tell you about
Tom's observation.
So first of all, the thing is,
with branching, is you that you
have that assumption, but that's
a very general assumption.
So one of the things that
inspirited me, actually,
to start doing all this, is that
I did an internship here, and
I was using Corral.
A lot of those things that I
kept doing all the time was
adding false assertions
to know how far my
explosion attempt went.
And I was like, yeah,
it's true that, yeah,
shell of bugs and all that.
But how far did it go?
Did I get after
the initialization look?
>> So basically can you prove
this a certain false for me?
You just sprinkle
the assert false?
>> I would sprinkle assert false
after certain loops, cuz I mean,
I know how many
iterations this can have.
>> But can you even get here?
>> Can I even get here?
>> Okay, sure [CROSSTALK]
>> It's hard to know
what happens.
>> It's a smoke test,
but I mean,
I'm not the type of
super novice user,
still I had to do some really
kind of dark stuff to make sure
that the model checker was doing
some of what I wanted it to do.
It's true, it's true,
but we need
at least a tiny window into
what's going on inside that.
>> A model checker can at least
do statement code for you,
because when it explores
a statement at least it reached.
You can say just like a test,
because it's fundamentally
executing the code.
>> We're gonna talk about
coverage in a couple of slides.
>> So the frontier so
the way you define the frontier
is a set of traces, right?
>> A set of traces,
that's right.
And your question was
actually very good.
So you might have an explanation
number of traces.
That's true, one of the things
is we don't say that we're gonna
present the whole set of traces.
We say that we're
gonna present some.
And why is that important?
Well, first of all,
because if you see one
trace that is too short you
might already realize that your
expression is not deep enough.
That's one of the things.
And then your other
question was, well,
you might have a ton of
traces that are very similar,
why is that?
Well, because inside the push,
you might have an if to whatever
condition happens then and
you have one path that goes
on the true condition, and
the other path it goes on the
false condition, so that's true.
And that's a problem that we
actually don't tackle
explicitly in our paper.
I did tackle in order to
look at the output and
what I do is basically
I group those traces.
What I look at is, for instance,
in this case API operations,
right?
So it's true that I don't
get the full detail,
but if I know that I didn't do
more than two loop iterations
of the main loop,
we would probably agree that
that's not a very
deep exploration.
Well, for none of
the examples that I checked
in the SV Comp benchmark,
I had never reached this third
iteration of loop, right?
So it does actually happen that
you don't really get that far.
And it really depends on how
non-deterministic your instance
is and so forth.
But it's not entirely crazy to
have these sort of instances.
>> I guess that you're
saying that these traces,
even if they are abstract
where [INAUDIBLE],
they cover the actual
ART when you hear it.
They might switch
traces of there.
>> That's right, yeah.
>> Well, that's okay if
you still know that you
they will cover your two pushes.
>> That's right, yeah.
>> And that's thing is?
>> Yeah, that's the sort of
insight that we wanna get.
Then we have safe cones and
what are safe cones?
Well, this is essentially
paths to the collapsed part of
the assumption right, so
this is the true nodes.
It's those places where
you managed to prove that
something was safe.
And let's see it with
an example, again, so
we have a verification
harness on the left.
That non-deterministically
chooses the mode of operation of
a system, right, and
we have mode one and mode two.
And our original verification
result be unknown,
table limit exceeded or
something like that.
What we get now is, well, the
system execution that only calls
mode one is the safe trace,
what does that mean?
Well, it means that your system
is safe to use under mode one,
because any extension of
it will also be safe,
that means there's no
assertion failure.
That's a very strong statement.
That's much better than what
you would get with testing.
And much better than what you
would get with an unknown
result, right?
But it's also detailed
enough to tell you that,
well, even though mode one has
been very successfully proved
safe than mode two is not so
good, right?
Because we get pretty much the
same case that we got before.
We didn't get past the situation
of the while loops, so
it gives you some insight into,
well,
maybe you can remove mode one
from your verification harness.
And then maybe you can pay
attention to mode two and
probably use another technique
because you're not making
progress with this, right?
This is all very manual,
though, I do admit that,
it's not like we're gonna get a
tool working right away, sorry.
>> [INAUDIBLE] I think
[INAUDIBLE] give an under
approximation instead of being
definitely sure about it, right?
>> That's right, yeah. So.
>> Yeah.
So, we're not gonna go over each
of these formulas right now,
but what I wanna emphasize is
that part of the work is that
we formalize what
the guarantees for
each of these parts
of the output are.
And what are the connections
between our output and
the safety guarantees because
I think that's relevant for
making it intuitive and
understandable.
But what we are gonna do is
go over these formulas and
how they apply to
the previous examples, right?
So, we have the first
example in which we saw
the exploration frontier.
And what does it mean
that we have push,
push in the exploration
frontier?
Well, it means, A,
that it's feasible, right?
It's an actual system execution.
You don't have to go checking,
well, can I actually ever
do two pushes in a row?
No, we actually checked that for
you because that's
a reasonable thing to do.
But then we also know that
whatever safety property
we were checking for, holes,
right that means that
your analysis is sound.
If there a bug in that trace
we would have found it.
And then you know basically the
same thing that you would know
for a test case.
Okay, it's right if you see
a test case that passes you now
very well that didn't fail which
is kind of intuitive, but still.
And then you get that
it's a maximal, right.
So that's the exact point where
the model checker
stopped analyzing.
So you know that
that's basically where
the frontier reached.
It's not like, well,
you might be exaggerating or
it might be more than
what it actually reaches.
No, that's the exact point
where things change from being
analyzed to not being analyzed,
and that can give you an insight
if you know something about
the underlying technique.
What about safe cones?
Safecones is pretty
much the same thing.
They're feasible, so you
actually you can use mode one,
it's not impossible to use it.
And then it's minimal.
So it's the strongest
guarantee that you can have.
And also while it is a cone
in the sense that we have
the property with
traces of SafeCone and
the extensions of SafeCone
which is the one over here.
And, well,
if the SafeCone is feasible,
then the property holds.
Right, that's basically it.
So, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Sorry?
>> [INAUDIBLE] if you
do mode one you're
guaranteed all
extensions are safe?
>> Yeah.
>> But how [INAUDIBLE]?
What does it correspond
to in real software?
>> Even in
a verification instance,
it would be pretty much the
example we had at the beginning.
So basically if you have some
weird optimization in your mode
of operation, and
that makes it super hard to
malcheck it whereas the other
one is straightforward but
is just super inefficient.
Maybe it would be
easier to check.
That's sort of the motivation.
Obviously, chicken and egg,
we don't really have big
verification do not take
manually and so on so anyway.
So what are the research
questions.
First, is this
>> Can I ask?
>> So yeah, sorry.
>> So yeah, so
>> So
[INAUDIBLE] has look at this
relationship in testing
verification.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And one of the things I think
she explored was this issue of I
can verify this part then I only
have to test the other part.
>> That's right.
>> How does that relate to this?
>> It's pretty similar.
The difference is that the goal
of this is to show it to a user
and basically, And
in the case of America's XG,
she's writing tests, and maybe
you would have to look at the
tests, that would be your goal.
It's kind of related.
It's a different
kind of analyzes.
Also, the type of foundations
that she has works for
a specific kind of techniques.
It doesn't really work for
the same techniques that
I'm trying to tackle.
>> Okay, so
>> So it's complimentary.
>> Yeah,
I dont know if the shoes do
>> Present one if
they're not the string?
>> I do just using Daphne, she
was not using like old program
modulars, she was just
using modular stuff.
So I mean it's a slightly
different use case basically.
So, research questions.
Well, is this practical
performance-wise?
So as you might be picturing
already, whether we have to,
what we have now is several
verification tasks.
We came from one that didn't
work well and now we have
several cuz we need to produce
several counterexamples.
So this might very well be no,
the answer to research
question one.
And then research
question two is kind of
related to what
you asked before.
Is this gonna be an exponential
number of traces?
Is this gonna be
manageable by users?
Ideally, we would wanna test
whether this is understandable
and useful.
I have to be honest with you,
we're not at this stage yet.
We don't have a clear use case
that we can conduct a user study
and be like, okay,
does this work better
than what you had before.
Again, chicken and egg,
we're not using verification for
anything so
it's kind of hard to tell.
Architecture, sorry,
>> You don't have a,
I saw you were using SV comp and
you had some benchmarks.
>> We have some benchmarks, but
we don't really know how
to conduct a user study
that would be a realistic use
case that is already a use case.
Cuz you don't have
any way to look into
verification results right now.
So you can't really
outperform that.
>> But you can show that if I do
things or you have a unit size.
>> Yeah what we have
is anecdotal evidence.
What I do is I go and
check the output and
say you didn't know this before
but I don't know if that is
there's not a user study
that's an author study.
So conducting a user study
means you have a user.
And you don't really have
similar techniques right now.
That's kind of the problem.
>> Did you go off [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah I did.
I went through every
single output.
>> Even for that. Perfect.
>> And I'm not
going to talk about
the other study because
that's not in
the published paper.
But, we can definitely talk
about it in the questions.
Yeah.
So our proxies is at least are
they manageable in size because
if it's not then why bother?
Right?
So this is the architecture.
You have a system
under verification.
You run it through your
software model checker.
That's abstract
reachability tree based.
That produces the assumption
of intelligence which is
the abstract reachability
tree structure.
And the input for
the two verification tasks
is the system under verification
and the ART structure, right?
And they're different and
they're independent in that they
have different targets, right?
In one,
we are targeting the notes in
the nodes in the waitlist,
which is the one that produces
the exploration frontier.
Then in the other one, we're
looking for the collapsed true
states and the assumption which
are the safe cones that's right.
>> So wait, so
I'm a little confused.
So you're doing three
model checking, yes?
Or you produce the and then you
have another model checker so,
I don't quite understand, so?
>> Yeah I'll go over it again.
>> So if you're applying
the same model checker to,
art gives you, the model
checker did something thing,
it gives you an art, and
then you ask it to explore
more from those states.
>> You ask it to explore it,
yeah the verification instance,
essentially what it does is
it composes the system with
the actual reachability tree.
>> Yes I understand.
>> And then you make queries.
>> It's basically the result of
running the first model checker.
>> Basically yeah and then you
make queries on top of that and
try to see which of those states
are actually feasible or not.
Cuz you're interested
in the true states and
the false states.
>> So but do you
>> Okay.
>> One detail about this, is
it doesn't have to be the same
model checker like
those three boxes.
>> Sure sure sure.
That
makes a little more
sense because I was
just wondering well how are you
gonna find any new information?
>> Yeah.
>> If those two are the same.
>> Right.
>> Okay so
this might be the case of
>> Like Daphne and
some other like DCE, I might
have different notions of
checking whatever the checking
is [CROSSTALK] right.
>> But the first thing when you
were in the model checker you
don't have the art
structure to start with.
>> [CROSSTALK] No,
I understand that.
So the second time no
I'm reading the diagram,
I'm just saying if you give
the end result Well maybe if
you give it more time and
it can just go.
>> It's not just about
giving it more time,
it's a different property so
it's gonna be a different
exploration all together.
Because you can have
an obstruction reflect.
>> It's conditional
because it's Based on the,
>> Yeah, absolutely but
since it's a different
structure,
it could trigger a different
obstruction refinements.
So it's not the exact
same exploration.
But I do agree and
there's actually results
in the evaluation.
>> Okay, cool, so
the model check can light up
many different parameters.
And the second time you do it,
you might tweak them.
>> Yeah, yeah. Right.
Absolutely.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Sorry.
>> Picture,
you're essentially creating
the art using these [INAUDIBLE].
You're asking some
properties in the art.
>> That's right.
>> As opposed to verification
just checking some property.
>> That's right.
>> This is saying
which part is really covered,
which part is not covered.
>> That's right.
So what we do is we run this
on 68 instances from SV-COMP.
These are the instances that the
conditional model checker paper
presented.
So we tried to not have any new
section advise in that, and
then we use two techniques
by dianalysis and lasik per
regular extraction, which are
very different in themselves.
And that's kind of shown
in that they time out for
almost entirely
different instances.
And then phase one of the
evaluation is we run this with
the 900 second time and
we run both techniques.
And then for those instances
that produce conclusive results
we run phase two.
And we generate
execution reports.
Right, with the same time limit
and we have both techniques.
Again, so we have basically
first value analysis and
then value analysis, or
then predicate abstraction,
and so on.
You see there's four
combinations, right?
>> I understand phase one
to be the leftmost box in
the previous slide.
>> The thing that
generates the ART.
>> Yeah, it's the left one.
Yeah, that's right.
>> And okay,
what are the results for this?
Well, we get nine inconclusive
results with value analysis in
the first phase, right?
We produce a full, and
then full means something.
I'm gonna explain what full
means, for interior ports for
five of those instances using
lazer predicate analysis.
And the average size is
12.2 ranging from 4 to 30.
It's not huge.
It's manageable.
>> Average size of what?
>> Of the execution role, so
the number of executions
in the full frontier set.
>> This is number
of traces okay.
>> Yeah that's right.
>> But how long
are the traces each of them?
They're very long,
I'm gonna talk about
that in a second, yeah.
[LAUGH] And the average time
limit is, well, 78 seconds,
that's kind of good, right?
Because it's less than 10% of
the original verification time.
>> Can you go back to
the previous slides
>> This one?
>> So, what are the sizes
of these code bases?
>> The size in terms
of lines of code?
It's about 1,000 lines each.
It might be,
some are a couple hundred,
some are a little
bit over 1,000.
They're not huge.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
So yeah, so
that's what value analysis is.
It's not great, but
it's for more than half of them,
you can produce a report within
a fraction of
the verification time, right?
So for
value analysis we then get the
safe component of the report.
We were talking about
different tier component.
Now we're talking about
the safe component.
Same, we only produce for 5.
Curiously, it's not the same 5.
So it's not like you can
produce the full report for
the instance.
And here the average
size is low, right.
It's just do one trace.
It goes from zero, too.
It's like it's not much.
And then the average time
goes up significantly.
Still, since we timeout
at 900 seconds it has to
be less than the original
verification time.
Yeah?
>> So is it the same set of 9
that gave inconclusive results?
>> Yeah.
>> It's really a property
in the program.
>> Yeah.
>> No matter what kind of
analysis you're doing.
The first one was
value analysis.
>> No this is both values.
>> This is both values but it's
two components, it's frontier.
>> It's frontier versus safe
okay now I get it okay.
>> Okay and then we'll move on
to those that timed out with
predictive analysis right?
And we get 16
inclusive results and
we produce a full frontier
report for 13 of those.
And curiously again it works
better using value analysis to
produce a report so just what
Tom had been saying about.
So, the average size in this
case, it's not that good.
It's 120, 118.3 traces.
That's not what I would
describe as manageable, right?.
That is a little too high.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sir?
>> Can you just [INAUDIBLE].
What is value analysis?
>> Variance is you keep track
of the values of the variables,
so that your quality.
>> I see okay, okay.
>> So you do a lot of enrolling
basically because you're gonna
have a different node for
each iteration of the loop
usually because you
increment the value and
then you have a different note.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yep, so yeah.
So average size goes up.
Average time still
is pretty low.
It's 10%, but
it can go up to 629 seconds,
which is not that low.
So 13 out of 16, given that
we're doing several, yeah?
>> So did you have an upper
limit of the time?
So 900 seconds,
was that for cases?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so you can't go over
that, that's what I was saying,
yeah.
>> But none of them actually
failed in the second phase?
It's not actually
finishing, right?
>> No yeah, yeah yeah,
because that's-
>> Because you only get five-
>> Yeah, you only get five so
four-fifths.
Fortune produced a full report,
and
I'm gonna talk about
that in a second.
>> Okay.
>> I'm sure I don't know where
I was, predicate analysis,
full frontier, here,
safe reports, same, 13.
It's not the same 13 though.
>> And again, what works
better is, analysis right.
And the average size in this
case is not great, it's 0.07.
So it means that for 12 of
those, it was zero traces and
then for one,
it had one safe trace and
we are going to talk about this
in the sort of conclusions of it
>> So when you say zero,
it just basically gives
you no information, right.
>> It finished, and
it proved that there was no
safe trace that was feasible.
>> Well, what that means they
were to capture any abstraction.
That it's safely extended,
tight?
>> That's right.
It means that the first attempt
did not prove any fraction of
the.
>> Right.
>> Any feasible [INAUDIBLE].
>> 900 second, I mean, why do
you give the same time you
might, or right you could be.
>> Give it longer,
what do you mean?
>> So I think your intuition
is that you don't want to
give it too much extra time
because the model checker would
have discovered some more right?
>> I mean my intuition
is this is the post
processing of
the verification done.
I mean if I'm gonna give it
five hours I might as well
give it a verification
time of five hours.
>> Yeah but
why 900 why not 90 seconds?
I feel like I mean it's
an arbitrary limit,
if its more than the original
verification time I feel like
it's no use of producing
a report that takes longer.
>> Sure but he's asking why
didn't you choose 900 for
the original verification.
>> That's standard for
I just used that.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> 900 for the second.
>> For the second, okay.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
Post-processing right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, you would might think,
well I should give
them 90 seconds.
>> 90
>> Just a little, 10% of the-
>> 10% [CROSSTALK].
>> I mean,
it could be definitely.
That's a fair question, I-
>> You could [CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah, but
he's got the distribution.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
>> [INAUDIBLE] In
the range of values.
>> I feel like more
than [CROSSTALK].
>> Sure,
because it completes, yeah.
>> I agree that more than 900
seconds is a lot than I don't
know if maybe 90 would
be maybe 15% would but
you can see the paper and
say okay.
>> Can you try to
push it further and
see if it goes an hour if
you get better reports.
>> Maybe,
I think that that's not a good
evaluation of whether
it's performance.
If I get an average
of 900 seconds,
I don't think it's really good.
So we still get 13.
The average time is somewhat
low, it's 55 seconds, so yeah.
And then one of the things that
is cool about these reports,
well in my opinion anyway
is that you can get some
value of it by even
seeing parts of it.
You don't need to get
the full report in order to
get information.
So if you see one trace
that tells you, okay,
you didn't explore more
than the first iteration,
and I know that any extension
of that trace is not explored.
Then you're maybe,
this is not really good, right?
This is not a really
good exploration.
And what I checked here is the
time until the first element of
either the safe cones, or the
expression frontier is produced.
And what we have here is
the combinations of different
techniques, right?
So we have, P stands for
predicate analysis, and E for
explicit value analysis.
And PP means that I ran
predicate analysis first, and
then I ran predicate analysis
for the generation, and so
on and so forth.
And what we get is that for
most instances, we can produce
a trace starting within half
of the verification time,
where you can also check it for
like 10%.
It's not great, but
you can produce it for
many instances with some
of those combinations.
And then,
what are the results or
the conclusions of
the evaluation?
Well, the technique
that he used for
the execution report definitely
affects the performance, which
is what Tom had the intuition
even before I talked about it.
And then the running time
does not seem prohibitive.
I mean, we can disagree on
whether it's 10%, 15%, but
it's not a multiple of 20
times the verification times.
The size of output,
on average, is usually fine,
but the maximum is
definitely not great.
What I do, and
that's kind of related to my
own inspection of the output,
is, you can group these traces
and sort of abstract them.
The problem with that is,
the semantics is not that
clear then, because well,
it's an existential semantic
on that abstraction.
So it means that there's
some concrete trace that
has been explored or
has not been explored, and it's
kind of fussy for an end user.
But for the purpose of
analyzing your output,
it was actually super useful.
I might write a paper about it
at some point, I don't know.
Anyway, definition of analyzed.
Well, that's the problem
with the safe zones.
What is the problem
with the safe zones?
Well, if you look at
the assumption of
sometimes what happens is that
trivially, by just extending
the from that place,
there's no reachable assertion.
So those are, by definition,
safe zones, right?
And what we're using,
we're sort of inheriting our
definition of what is analyzed
is what we get as the output
of conditional model checking.
So paying attention to what
has been analyzed is part of
explaining these
inconclusive results,
because it's not really
trivial to do that.
If you want to explain
this to a user,
you might wanna spend a little
bit more time making trivial
extensions to your exploration
frontier, basically.
So, yeah,
that's kind of a conclusion and
sort of future work.
>> [INAUDIBLE] initial
model checker was smart,
you could have already thought
of some more safe zones.
>> Yeah, not really.
What I'm saying is, if you do
a really dumb post-processing
on the assumption of you
can get better results.
Sorry?
>> So it'd be useful to
understand what this looks like
concretely, like if I
see one of these traces.
>> Yeah.
>> And also it'd be
useful to actually understand,
were there cases where the trace
led you to look at the code, and
understand why something
was analyzable [CROSSTALK]?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So, well,
why wasn't it analyzable?
So let me explain
a little bit about that.
I was hoping to talk about
it in the questions, but
let's talk about it now.
Anyway, so what I did in the
first iteration of this paper
was, go over all the outputs and
check what
insights could I get from
what I was producing, right?
>> Right.
>> And the first problem
that you bump into is,
the traces are huge, so
you can't deal with that.
So what do you do?
Well, you look at
the stack depth,
cuz that gives you an idea of
how far into you're in, and
you filter some of it, because
you don't really care about it,
and you group them together.
And you maybe had like 150 and
now you have five.
And then, you look at the stack
depth, and you see that
you have two methods that get
called in a sequence, and
you're like,
maybe there's a loop there.
I didn't know them,
so I don't look at sb.com
code in my free time, so
I didn't know the instances.
>> Right.
>> So what I did was, okay,
you have a trace, and
then let's look at the code.
Where does this
method get called?
It gets called in one place.
It's the main loop
of the program.
And what you see is that your
exploration frontier maybe
reaches the second
iteration of the loop.
But you got all of that
understanding from maybe looking
at one trace and
then grabbed on the code.
If you wanted me to do that by
looking at the absolute utility
tree and the code, I don't
know if I could of done that,
that's what I'm saying.
I think it gives you an insight
that you couldn't get from just
the raw material, basically.
But yeah, you still require
some post-processing to make it
be manageable.
Because these are long traces.
It has every single statement
to make the semantics sort
of clear.
>> Right, I guess I'm trying to
understand how it's actionable.
In other words, if you give me
the trace, and I'm a developer.
Cuz the way I was thinking about
it, too, is you could stop and
give me this abstraction,
and then I look at it, and
I use my brain to
understand what's going on.
>> But-
>> Or you can just
let the mal-checker
continue to run.
>> Yeah.
>> So
my brain time is worth a lot
more than the final check of
the CPU time.
>> Absolutely, but
how far will it get by giving
it twice as much time?
That's an experiment that we
didn't do and we should do yeah.
>> No, but I do think
that this question about
like what's the human
process afterward, right?
And how long does that take?
That's a fair question.
>> I agree,
it's a fair question.
So the way I envision it is,
you're asking, well why don't
I just let it run longer?
The problem is that if
you let it run longer,
you're in the same position
that you were before, which is,
what did it do?
Is it good enough or not, right?
>> But it might find, for
instance, your errors, right?
>> It might find errors, but
let's consider the case-
>> But that's what I'm saying.
The comparison is that,
you let it run an hour,
it finds something or
it doesn't, or
you give it to me and
you give me an hour, right?
>> Yes.
>> The question in my mind
is will I find errors
in that hour, right?
It's what you're
giving to the human.
I've been spending more time
on Excel spreadsheets, but
the point is,
there is a sort of [INAUDIBLE],
my brain is doing something
when you give me information.
And the question is, can't
we emulate that instead of,
when you take that output,
I think the computer
can understand your outputs
better than my brain, but
the question is,
how do you do that?
>> I think the problem is that
it's a fundamentally different
task, that's the thing.
One thing is to go
bug finding and
another one is to define whether
whatever attempt that you did
was good enough or not,
that's the problem.
So if you're using,
for instance,
the static driver verifier, and
you reach the whatever bound,
iteration bound and
you didn't find any bugs.
And you're leading the company
that does drivers or
does hardware or whatever, how
do you know if that's enough or
not, or
if you need more testing?
Should you use only verifier,
or pay your engineers for
an hour of extra testing?
If you-
>> That's a great question.
So the key question
of the research is,
how do you take the output
of what you have [LAUGH] and
give somebody the ability
to make that decision?
>> Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
And that's kind of where
coverage comes in, right?
Cuz, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE] What you could
have done is a human can look at
it and come up with some local
variance that if you had written
the program the model checker
would have just finished.
>> Yeah, definitely.
That assumes that your user
is an experienced user,
which I'm trying not to,
cuz that limits my impact.
But yeah,
you can definitely do that.
>> But I think that,
anyway, we can go into this
offline, but just giving
coverage information and saying,
well I got here, is one extreme.
The other is, you can say well,
at this program point I
learned this variance.
And that variant might, well,
might not be parsimonious.
It might have all sorts of
variables that aren't relevant
and confuse the user, but it
might be worthwhile persisting,
that the user might
get some insight.
You discovered something
interesting about my code.
And that takes up
a lot more time than,
like inspecting
a coverage report.
You got here, good.
Or you didn't get here.
So I think there's still like
a spectrum of information that
the model checker has.
And it's not exactly clear,
there's a whole design
space there right?
Because with predicate
abstraction you have these.
Formulas of the predicates,
you might have learned
interesting facts.
Is it useful?
Don't know.
So, yeah, I mean,
I think the reachability tracer
discards a lot of that, right?
>> I mean, kind of.
I think it depends on what kind
of a nodes you're using.
If you're using
a reachability tree,
you're most really not going to.
>> Yeah, sure, sure, so let's
take it offline, all right,
I think it's [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
we can talk about it later,
yeah.
So coverage, so
one of the questions is okay
you got that report and
how do you know whether
it's good enough or not?
Should I stop model checking or
not and, well,
an obvious solution to that is,
well, everyone, it sounds
a lot like adequacy, right?
So what's verification adequacy?
I don't know.
And I don't think you
guys know either.
But can we size these execution
is there any way to do that?
And then,
it'd be cool if we got some of
the users that use coverage.
We don't have that many users.
So anyway one of the problems
with defining coverage and
you might be like, okay,
I'll just output whatever
statements they covered.
And one of the problems
that what if you're doing
incremental search, right?
So you're doing loop enrolling
or something like that and
you have this example, right?
So this is only one
system execution, right?
And it always reaches a so
we have an identification time,
that rolls this loop for
a number a times.
And it takes for ever and
I timeout, right?
And what do I say about that
statement, is it covered,
it is not?
It seems like a kind
of trivial question.
Well, it doesn't really matter,
it's just about a definition.
But what if it's a book
of statements, right?
And this could
arbitrarily inflate your
coverage measure, right?
So there's really no, I mean,
this is fundamentally different
to testing, because you don't
know if your verification does
not run to completion, tests do.
So you don't know if you
reach the assert, right?
But this is not
gonna be a problem.
Because you might be telling me,
I don't use that.
I don't use incremental search,
cuz that's not efficient.
I use modular analyzers, right?
But the problem is
you're probably using
over-approximation, because you
have infinite state spaces,
you have state explosion.
And if you don't
over-approximation,
your model checker
doesn't scale either.
So you have this problem, and
you have reached that code
which obviously is dead code.
And you find that you're using
[INAUDIBLE] extraction and
you find [INAUDIBLE], right.
Because you were not
tracking the predicate.
But again,
we have no linear arithmetic.
Your model checker gets up there
and internally it's [INAUDIBLE],
for instance,
would have that [INAUDIBLE]
in its representation, right?
And, well, should we consider
it covered, does it count, or
does the coverage count or not?
Well, I don't know, those are
the decisions that people make,
and I made my decision.
My decision this is basically
sort of a general framework,
this is not actually tell you
what any of the previous example
should give you, but
what it tell you,
is you need basically some
terminating execution, right?
And why some
terminating execution?
Because that's the way to work
around the problem of verifying
of checking whether you've
checked an assertion or not.
You have a terminating
execution, well,
if your code had any assertions,
you're gonna reach it, right?
The exercise in statement S
within an analyzed portion of
T, right?
So that whole predicate,
I'm not telling you what it is,
because it depends on heavily
on what technique you're using.
And I'm gonna talk about it next
slide for [INAUDIBLE] trees,
right?
And then I ask that
the terminating execution
is actually safe, cuz if I found
a counterexample I shouldn't be
computing coverage, I should
be fixing the bug, right?
So what does it mean for
abstract reachability trees?
Well, first of all,
why abstract reachability trees?
Well, because I was
working with that and
it makes sense as a first step.
But actually in our paper
that we're gonna get feedback
tomorrow, [LAUGH], we talk about
some extensions of this for
other techniques sort
of on a high level.
And then what does it mean for
absolute reachability trees?
Well, we offload the whole
hasn't been analyzed to
the conditional model checking
predicate side, right?
So when has something
been analyzed?
Well, it's been analyzed if
it reaches only nodes outside
the reachability tree waitlist,
right?
So remember we talked
about the trees.
We have waitlist which
correspond to stuff that
hasn't been explored yet.
If you reach one of those,
well, then it means that
you've gone outside of
the analytics space, right?
If you haven't
reached one of those,
then you remain within
the analyzed portion.
>> What is p q is that a state?
>> No,
I didn't explain that part, so
what we have is some
terminating execution t.
We have p which is a prefix,
right?
And it's an analyzed prefix,
so it remains within
the abtergility tree.
And the statement is
within the prefix of
the terminating execution.
So this kind of raises
the bar a little bit for
verification techniques.
Because you not only have to
have it within your structure,
or your internal representation,
but it also has to be part
of a physical execution.
And, sorry.
This is not what I was,
anyway, so research questions.
Is this a kind of producer
reasonable under-approximation
of this within original
verification time?
Again, why do I have to
under-approximate it?
Why don't I compute
the exact coverage?
Well, because that's
probably not computable, but
I don't know it can just
time out, you don't know how
many system you have anyway so
we're producing.
>> Can't that just be done
online while you're checking,
given the property?
>> Kind of it depends whether
you have system executions
or not.
If you have terminating
executions,
you can just check how
much of that you cover.
And that's one of the use
cases that we consider.
But that would be
an unfair comparison,
because that would be like,
I computed on the fly well.
But you need to have
those executions, so
you have to pay that
cost at some point.
So those system executions,
yeah?
>> [INAUDIBLE] because it's.
>> So what I have is
a terminating execution t.
>> Yeah, you don't know.
Sorry, I forgot about that.
>> I need to-
>> Yeah, okay.
I am sort of a witness that this
is an actual system integration
that it's not just
made up safe space.
So anyway.
So that's one of
the research questions, and
then the other one is,
but do [INAUDIBLE].
So is actually cover, and
it got, because anybody checked.
So [LAUGH] we do is ideally
we would want to write manual
tests and compare their coverage
of that with our model checker
coverage but that is just
kind like apple and oranges.
Like how do you compare
the effort into going for
both things?
So what we do is compare
it against an automatic
test generation tool, like CLI.
Here the architecture,
same case as before.
We have a code, then we have
the Software Model Checker that
produces and the assumption.
That's a condition side that
conditional law checking
talks about.
Then we have this whole pipeline
and then it's a loop, right?
We have on the left,
on the far left,
we generate a specification that
captures the sort of properties
that a the terminating
fusion will have.
Then that specification
is fed into
another software mall checker.
It could be a different one.
And that software mall checker
produces those safe terminating
executions that might have
additional properties or not.
And then we take those safe
terminating executions and
we check how those executions
are covered by
the condition psi, right?
Then we update
the coverage statistics.
Then we feed those back
to the specification.
Why do we have that
feedback loop?
Because in, for instance,
checker right now,
you can give it a specification
that tells you, okay,
I want to cover this
one line in particular.
So every terminating
execution that we generate
is the terminating execution
that increases the coverage,
which might not be the case.
>> And these are totally
executional that as a witness to
the correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Not just random execution
>> No, I mean,
if you produce a bug or
[INAUDIBLE], you report the bug,
which could happen.
It actually does,
it's in the evaluation.
So what do we do?
Same instances.
Sorry.
But please start a [INAUDIBLE]
who just produce random path
right?
It's forcing it to go
through the search.
>> I think it has two modes,
I think it has two traversals at
the same time and
it does a round robin.
I don't really know
the details of that, but
anyway yeah Klee
will not give up.
If it finds an insertion it will
continue producing test cases.
It doesn't really care,
it will report them but
it will continue producing.
So we use the same instances.
Phase one is the same thing,
and phase two for
those with inconclusive results,
we can compute the coverage and
we create a test
suite using KLEE.
And we duplicate the time
spent right because well
we're not just verifying but
we're also computing coverage.
So KLEE to be fair
has doubled down.
So reasonable
under-approximation
within the original
verification time?
Well, let's look at
the technique separately.
So we have value analysis.
And, I should have, yeah,
this is the wrong
way of showing this.
So for five of the instances we
produced an under approximation
that is between 40 and
87 percent of the over
approximation.
Let me talk about what
the over approximation is.
So CBH already produces
the coverage statistic.
But how does it produce it?
But remember those problems that
I talked about at the beginning,
that maybe you would have
a code that's not reachable and
maybe you would have
prefixes that would
to a series of close assertions
well, that's how the pris is.
It's a very coarse,
overapproximation.
But we don't have
the exact measures, so
we use that, anyway.
So in this case it's not ideal,
but I mean it's for more than
half of the instances we produce
a reasonable underapproximation.
And then, for two of them,
we find bugs, so
then we give up on the first,
I mean the, so
only for two instances we don't
really produce anything useful.
Then laser break.
>> It's really not useful then?
>> What does not useful mean?
>> That we don't
produce anything, for
two we don't produce output,
that's the definition of useful.
>> Does it time out or?
>> Yeah you time out producing.
>> The same result
that CPA prints.
>> Okay.
>> No no no CPA checker always
gives you an approximation
because you get.
>> That's what I
was gonna say so
>> There has to be another way
to not be useful.
>> Yeah.
>> But is 87% is not meaningful
because an over-approximation
doesn't give you much insight
right, of coverage.
>> No, but I mean if you
if you always get 0% or
if you always get 10%
then it's really bad.
If you get 87% you're you
know you're pretty close to
to the actual number.
>> Then for
lazy predicate abstraction
then you got 16 instances.
And then for 11 of them you get
something that's between 55 and
100% of the over-approximation.
For three of them it's
special cases basically.
One of them it has zero
coverage because the exit is
actually unreachable, whereas
CBA shaker would report 267
lines of 388 covered, right?
So that's how bad, how inflated
the coverage could be, right?
For another,
while you have bugged phone, so
it doesn't really make
sense to compute coverage.
And for another one,
we get an obstruction.
We find an error
which is basically
something we could work around.
It's just we chose the wrong
technique maybe, but
it's not absolutely unworkable.
And then for two we produced
a completely useless result,
which is nothing.
But then, how do we do
convergent test generation?
Well, for.
15/23 instances SMC coverage is
in other forms KLEE coverage.
And moreover for 6/23 which is
more than 25% of the instances
were multiple of the coverage
that KLEE produces.
And only for a couple instances
we do get smaller coverage,
it's less than 80% of
what KLEE covered.
So that's pretty much
the conclusions of the coverage
part, and I'd just like to
summarize a little bit of
what I've talked about during
the talk, and talk a little bit
about future work which is, I
think, is kind of interesting So
basically the key takeaway,
focus on inclusive results.
I think that's
super interesting.
Having formal guarantees for the
output, also super interesting,
so that users can know
what to expect about it.
Then building a proof
of concept and
evaluating it can
give you insights.
I think that's interesting and
super relevant, and
you need to do it.
And then for the reports,
basically the key contribution
is just idea of producing
the with concrete guarantees
that make it easy for
your users.
And then coverage.
The contributions
are the overview of
the challenges, then.
A measure that can be compared
to test case generation.
That's useful.
Anyway, future directions.
Short term?
Stronger guarantees for
coverage.
That'd be cool.
I have the intuition that there
is something about the breath of
verification attempt that we're
not capturing by using the same
semantic that you would have
in test case generation.
Then improving usability parts
is what you mentioned it's long
traces we have to pay attention
to that, we have to find
that makes sense and
is still intuitive for users.
And reports for other we talked
about this a little bit in
the coverage paper that we wrote
but, it would be interesting to
implement it and
actually test it.
Because we don't know what the
coverage is for many things and
it would be interesting
to know it.
Then techniquing time limit
recommendation that would be
basically there's tons of
portfolio approaches to
statically choosing the best
tool for a certain instance and
you use structural features
such as do you have lubes,
do you have Floating point.
Do you have pointer arithmetics
and stuff like that?
And certain tools are better for
this and
they're better for that.
But what if you have
a short list of four or
five tools and
you run them in parallel?
You can prioritize them but
looking at their intermediate
results that we're getting
is more insight into this.
I think this is
an obvious next step.
But what about longer term?
Well I'm mentioning it again,
coverage and
intermediate results,
for other techniques.
And why am I
mentioning it again?
Because I think we can
take the path backwards.
If we had a representation
that's actually sharable and
between different techniques
such as coverage,
you could have much more
aggressive on sound assumptions. Right?
Because it wouldn't make sense
in that context
to provide techniques that
can increase the coverage. Right?
Because this coverage is useful.
I think this could lead to and
telling new families of
techniques that would make sense
in that context and that right
now might be too specific and
you might not have
a previous case for them.
Then a special case
of this is right?
So you might have, a very
demonic environment, and what
you're trying to do is filter
all those false positives.
And correct me if I'm saying
anything wrong because
you're here, but one of
the things that you can do is
make the things work together.
What if you could
instead of filtering out
sort in specifications, if you
could rang them using coverage
as a proxy for how reasonable or
unreasonable they are.
Well of course we have
to conduct large scale.
Studies, basically knowing
whether the results for
test case adequacy hold for
or if they're different.
Then building other
types of reports would
certainly make sense.
What I've recommended,
it's only good for
absolute reach-ability trees,
but if your doing modular
analysis all of that breaks
down and is not really useful.
Then user studies.
That's basically the only way to
validate that what we're doing
makes any sense.
And to integration basically
is the step forward and
making that vision that I
talked about at the beginning
at least closer to true.
So that's all that
I had to say and
thank you very much for
your time.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> All right we'll talk later.
>> I just have one question.
So obviously [INAUDIBLE] so
[INAUDIBLE] that
they do [INAUDIBLE].
Is there a equivalent kind of
effort externally in the open
source community?
Around using because I guess one
question I had would be what's
the path that you're most
immediate practical use of this.
>> I think the path to the most
immediate practicability is
basically the that, integrating
some of these tools to an IDE.
And I think the obvious
place to do that.
Is Visual Studio because
>> But you have to start with
a developer community that's
actually doing this in some way,
right?
>> Well that's what I'm saying,
so
you already have all those tools
integrated into Visual Studio.
Yeah, yeah.
>> Microsoft does,
I'm just curious if
anybody else does?
>> At least that I know of
there's nothing like that.
There's similar stuff in,
there's [INAUDIBLE] integrated
but it's more like pattern
matching certain smaller things.
And it's more light
weight stuff, then,
you do have some concert
efforts into, for instance,
like the Linux driver
verification effort.
But all of that is usually
using one or two tools and
it's a very close community.
It's not,
I don't think that Linux driver
developers are using that.
I think it's
the other way around.
It's just a closed, like a more
closed verification community
trying to find bugs
in Linux drivers.
>> I see, so it isn't
the developer community sort of
pulling it, it's the
verification community pushing
[CROSSTALK]
>> And I mean,
it kind of makes sense cuz if
you're not providing something
that can give consistent value,
why would your developer use it?
I mean, I don't know.
I don't think there's
mutual support.
>> Well, it's pretty clear
on the Microsoft side of it,
it does add value, right?
And it's been used for
ten years, so I'm just curious,
even though we've
been doing this and
shown that it actually adds
value, why or where is sort of
this kind of effort is
actually placing externally?
>> As far as I know there's
no other place in which it
takes place.
I think there's a few
reasons why that's the case.
We can talk about it offline.
>> Sure we can.
>> One of the reasons is could
be Microsoft started investing
a lot before starting to
see value in the STV space.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm sure,
I think it's
a significant investment.
>> So side driver verifier,
for instance,
you can't replicate that
anywhere else because you don't
have outsider companies writing.
You don't have a company
with control over
Linux that can sort
of give those tools.
>> A central authority for
[INAUDIBLE], but you'd think
that in the end a tool chain
around doing mouse checking,
right, for a particular class
of problems like finding bugs in
drivers would
become widely used.
I think one of the things
that's interesting,
Microsoft had a real problem
with drivers, right?
>> Yeah.
>> It's this issue of like
the machine crashes and
you blame it on Microsoft, so
we had a very strong incentive
to not have that happen.
You'd think that Linux CBD would
have the same problem, right?
Is that when something crashes
in Linux, it's like, why?
Well, it's the driver was bad,
right?
>> Yeah, I don't think there's
significant pinpoints and
the problem is basically
your community's different.
Like if something crashes in
Linux, yeah I mean well I just
downloaded something that
a random guy wrote somewhere.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I didn't pay for this.
>> I'll fix it.
I'll [LAUGH] figure it out.
I don't know.
I guess it's different for
a company.
And there's no really
great incentives for
anyone to invest in that,
basically.
So I think it's there's
compelling reasons why that
doesn't happen
outside Microsoft.
>> All right, we can talk later.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> All right,
thank you very much.